[Music]
isn't here anymore
[Music]
let me suck your
[Applause]
[Music]
could you please clear the room
oh man i feel like crap just came from a
trashy indian restaurant in a strip mall
not bad food though got pretty lucky got
the hottest baddest curry ever ate in my
life this place called nonsense indian
joint just like terminal three it's like
i'm going to my brother's wedding on
sunday it's like i don't even want to go
i don't even like my brother my
brother's like a jerk but like his wife
she's like a [ __ ] i stayed with him for
like three weeks she was a [ __ ] to me
man i put my feet on her coffee table
she was like don't get your feet on my
top and like who are you
a
broad man like those are the worst
people on the planet so i said that too
i said that to him in the parking lot i
cornered him a little bit sure but he
swung on me man
he swung on me can you believe that it's
like who swings and their own brother
man yeah i swung back you know
but that's cool you know it's like i
haven't seen him for a while but now got
this expensive wedding i have to go to
so it was crazy i got to get my uh
tickets and that's the whole situation i
hate doing that and hold on a second hey
hey pow pal
starting on the downstairs bit it's a
middle of a conversation i'm here
hey i've got it i've
thank you
sorry about that
my little guy here uh
working on like
from the eternal
from within
yes
and hopefully you know i can get like
2000 one evening you know and speaking
of two down and one anything if they've
got popcorn shrimp and little lobster
rolls
[Music]
stop
who goes there
[Laughter]
everything is changing
what do you mean the end is near
there's nothing you can do
the end is near
everything is changing
from the eternal from within no i don't
want to die
[Music]
sorry about that man of course
change is coming
[Music]
happy sunday esther happy sunday
georgina
how was your week oh the lord is with me
mm-hmm but the devil
he got his hands on my grandniece grace
oh no mm-hmm they're smoking the reefer
doing the hanky-panky with boys no dawg
or esther you know
that i love all things that are good and
holy
but if he
doesn't let go of my grandness grace
i'm gonna cut the devil's dick off and
shove it in his ass
[Music]
with my prayers i know you will joe gina
i know you will
how was your weak girl oh you know me
i'm blessed and thankful for everything
mm-hmm all right but you know my
grandson jason got himself wrapped up in
the leathery claws of satan not jesus he
got himself arrested for the spray
painting and the vandalism oh lord and i
tell you i never
raised my hand in anger but if he don't
let jason go i'm gonna punch that [ __ ]
satan in the nuts so hard it wiped the
dick licking smirk off his horned-ass
face
with my prayers amen i know you will
esther i know you will but esther i
gotta tear you something else now oh let
it out you know esther that i have found
serenity in the glory of heaven yes but
my daughter's husband bernard has got
himself wedged between the cleft hooves
and lucifer herself
she opened up her laptop computer
and found the pornography of women not
the pornography absolutely the
pornography of women not on a laptop
computer
i am a pacifist under god's request but
if he don't let go of bernard i'm gonna
sneak up on that [ __ ] ass lucifer
right in the midst of his sleep time
and then i'm gonna sit on that
[ __ ] head and i'm gonna spread
my booty cheeks on that pig's face and
i'm gonna just pucker up my stink hole
and just tubes tubes tubes scoops
until that [ __ ] got a brown dot on his
nose that i can use for target practice
with your prayers of course of course oh
georgina georgina georgina
oh i got nothing but faith and god in
heaven above but i tell you my son's
wife crystal she got herself wrapped up
in the fiery wings of mephistopheles
herself here we go you know she got
caught using profanity with her own
children what at the dinner table oh
lord chad
oh i have nothing but love for every
creature on this planet but if he don't
let my darling crystal go i'm gonna
flirt with the devil oh oh
show him a little bit of shoulder how
you doing he's gonna start looking away
i'm gonna start twerking start twerking
he's gonna be like where he's gonna be
he's gonna be drawn in seduce that
little [ __ ] you can one of these
my eyelashes adam then when at least
expects it and i got his trust that's
when i'm gonna ride that [ __ ] i'm gonna
give him the night of his life and now
he ain't never gonna forget don't you
don't give him this way i'm gonna give
him that way and then right when he
about to climax that's when i'm gonna
clinch up my [ __ ] on that
motherfucker's red dick and i'm gonna
snack that [ __ ] [ __ ] off with a divine
kegel well you gotta snap that little
[ __ ]
with your prayers with your prayers of
course with the prayers yeah but that's
right girl yeah you go get him out yes
[ __ ] satan [ __ ] him [ __ ] him indeed
[Music]
what's happening
[Music]
[Applause]
oh give me some of that
i want a piece of him
who is this crazy [ __ ] now ah it's me
[ __ ] your wife's
nightmares right the [ __ ] i'm on top of
you
what's going on this feels good why
would you do this to me oh you're seeing
a sucking [ __ ]
i swear
hi
you must be liam
hey buddy how are you feeling today
i'm feeling fine dr
just fine
this is miriam glass and she's from the
make-a-wish foundation
marian glad
how are you feeling today liam
i'm fine mary in glass good well i have
some news that might make you feel a
little better huh we at the make a wish
foundation make dreams come true for
little boys and little girls who are
very sick just like you
there are no children like me mary in
glass
of course not you're one of a kind but
we're gonna make any dream come true
that you could ever have okay anything
that's right buddy that's right
would would you like to play with your
favorite basketball team
what about being superman for a day
i wish
to drown a man
what
to drown a man in the bathtub
to hold him down while the last
breath escapes his body and then
[Music]
liam
you said anything
surely we don't want to hurt other
people now
do we you know
any anything else fly in a hot air
balloon or
meet a celebrity
my new wish
is to lean over the body of a dying man
and put my lips on his
stealing his last breath
no one will get hurt no absolutely not
i don't even know where you i wish
to take all the prosthetic legs in the
hospital
and bind them together
with the dried flesh of the dead
into a
webbed
massive creature
liam
i am so sorry miss klaus it's all right
he he doesn't know what he's saying i
wish to pee in your mouth what
both of you
mine especially you
oh i wish to pee in both of your mouths
as i stand over you i'll need a glass of
water in ten minutes enough
dr gupta
no you're reprehensible
you are evil
you are a devil child
dr gupta he's not a devil child he's
just a child you have no business
working in a pediatric ward what i'm
going to report you
shame on you
[Music]
shame on
[Music]
this is insane
you've made me question everything that
i've ever believed about
the essential goodness of the children
wish
granted
[Music]
i am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]